[Music]
trust me that and that hurts and that
hurts merch to say so you know he means
it can we talk about somebody that is
making a difference
proud of our boy
literally now he's a proud boy we can
say proud of your boy they've been
calling him a proud boy so proud of your
boy buddy alex stein
i i i love alex knight my favorite
people
he was hanging out with the crew who
we've had all of them on cassidy
campbell
alex rosen you know the three amigos the
three [ __ ] amigos
this is him talking to ted cruz
if you care about america why do you do
that to your constituents when they're
freezing cold you know i'm sure you
think you're really smart oh i am smart
yeah because you're a globalist you do
more for ukraine you do for america you
know that remember how trump made fun of
your
so can i
get him alex can i just say right now
a lot of you guys were worried
a lot of you guys were worried when he
signed with blaze
and a lot of you people were like he's
gonna be a [ __ ] now now he's just gonna
sell out
now he's just gonna like suck all these
establishment republican guys dicks oh
man it's the beginning of the end of
alex stein
he's been going after a lot of rhinos
lately
so i
i wouldn't worry
i don't see this blaze thing having
changed him much
i think that uh blaze has been getting a
lot of young blood yeah
i never wanted to go hard younger the
younger young the young go hearts
become best friends it's a and by the
way
it's understand something with the blaze
so you guys get it and to quote the
family guy thing it's not art
it's commerce
and whatever's getting the clicks and
whatever's making money that's what
matters the trump factory makes fun of
you and your wife why do you do that
i understand you don't want it because
you're texting you don't want to see i
do love america so you don't you care
more about the border between uh ukraine
and russia than you care about the
border between texas and mexico well i
got one of t what a ted cruz's assad
agents is going to excuse me security
guards
is going to push alex back by the way
alex is not doing anything aggressive
here nope
he never does he knows what he's doing
he knows how to he knows how to stay
within the realm of decency
he's just telling you what you are and
and he's proving that these guys
cannot stand
peacefully being told what they are
i will say this
ted cruz
to his credit
even though everything alex is saying is
right about him handled this way better
than dan crenshaw did
zach
why do you care about god bless you i
know but why are you globalist you're a
globalist but you know it ted hey teddy
you're ready
you're a globalist ted you know that bud
and that's why you're a coward and a
liar and you know that and i know that
and that's why you're afraid to stand up
for when people were freezing and dying
you were in cancun mexico you remember
that you remember when you're at the
all-inclusive buffet why people were
freezing
no but do you remember that ted when
everybody was freezing remember that
when people were dying what were you
doing
no
what can i say
cassidy campbell always got it can i
give him credit always goes undercover
he's there with a maga hat he always
blends in a [ __ ] america trump trump
on a tank shirt he always has some sort
of cultural version of a ghillie suit
right
i love that description he's just always
cultural ghillie you always end up going
oh [ __ ] cassidy campbell's here how long
has he been here he's been here the
whole day and you're like [ __ ] he's good
what he's like um what's his face the
dude from the a team
oh face yeah face face from the a team
holy [ __ ] they're the a team yeah he's
literally yeah he's just oh can somebody
get them a black guy with a mohawk
do it they go to the [ __ ] children
and he's sitting there with pink hair
and a [ __ ] trance protect trans kid's
shirt
he's he's doing molly just to stay in
garrett wearing a better for president
hat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
they call them a democrat and he goes
i'm not a democrat because that's their
go-to oh you're a liberal you must be by
the way the wrong guy
everybody this guy famously everybody
knows alex now this isn't like
some rando guy the people alex stein is
known all right alex stein's been on
[ __ ] tucker and you're making
yourself look like fools by calling them
a [ __ ] liberal yeah exactly except
because it's dude it's good what you
said earlier it's exactly what you said
earlier
they can't imagine that people that are
on their side politically would be
attacking them this needed to happen
this is needed to happen how many times
did people call it [ __ ] shouldn't all
true how dare you what these people need
to be called out
you know alan warren in the chat says
they should get barricade garage to be
the mr t oh i love that and also wasn't
ba barakas wasn't he like the car guy
yeah wasn't he like the stunt driving
like mechanic dude he probably in the
car has a truck like that already yeah
he probably has a pimped out jeep let's
do it get barricade on this bad boy
let's let's go let's make an a-team
you know he'd end up being like yo man
but i'm wearing all them gold chains and
[ __ ]
i'm not a [ __ ] gimmick bro
all right that's fine
[Laughter]
i am going to do the mohawk though
because that [ __ ] looks tight
i'm telling you man let's do it alex
stein's the main guy
what's the old guy yeah what's his face
the cigar
i i love this
i like it
yeah i understand they don't want you
here
okay
hey
free speech doesn't exist no it doesn't
he's a globalist did you see cassidy
campbell leaning in
free speech doesn't exist i love this
man this little back and it's a great
crew
because you know what alex has to leave
but you know who gets to stay
cassidy gets his thing and now you gotta
now we just need alex rosen walking
around but with a stolen security guard
outfit yes yes you know
hey what were you doing
i got it what were you doing while he
was in cancun cassidy is playing yeah up
this is great
what does that mean out of what out of
my mom's womb what are you talking about
okay are you out of
what does that even mean because again
these people can't imagine that somebody
that votes like them would be calling
them out they need to be called out all
of these [ __ ] need to be called out
how are you going to this got you a
cover of the a-team theme i i know i
think oh okay let's see
oh thank you okay so here's here's the
thing
unlike other people and don't get me
wrong we like watching videos of owning
libtards that stuff's funny don't get me
wrong i'm not saying it's not but
there's a million of those you know and
i'm not saying i'm not saying this to no
disrespect i'm just saying there's a
million of the flekus talks videos out
there or campus reform which don't get
me wrong we'll place play some of those
again some of those are funny but
there's millions of people going out
there and owning the libtards how many
people up until recently have been going
up and call it and calling out the
people on there on their side that's the
only way [ __ ] changes because if not you
have 10 [ __ ] republican senators that
are going to vote for gun laws they
don't care about their constituency they
should be called out when they're
[ __ ] rhinos they should be [ __ ] i
don't think ted cruz is a rhino okay i
think ted cruz is a neocon i think
there's a little bit of a difference
um i think that when push comes to shove
other countries matter more to these
people and they need to be called out
i'm [ __ ] glad alex is doing this [ __ ]
i'm glad these people are doing that but
now let's get to the [ __ ] fun one
eyepatch mccain hey eyepatch mckay
here we go i patch mccain you know he
hates that name now
look at i passed mccain right here
you're rhonda you're flawless you're
globalist right now
you're a globalist rhino
hey you're a globalist rhino
i passed mckay
i passed
look at cassidy screaming and calling
him a traitor
[Music]
whoa
to continue
you know the more i think about it it
takes a lot of gall for eye patch mccain
to attack mom's jewelry about baby
formula as quote pro russia i mean
that's probably one that's one of the
most outrageous things i think i've ever
heard well that's the thing too he made
it very clear that that nickname
bothered him yep and they had a whole pr
little blitz to go after tucker about it
so now he's just trying to make that
stick and now let's go a little bit more
oh wait ron hold on we have more
no no no where is it where is it hold on
sorry guys here it is
so i don't know if you know this
okay but dan crenshaw's pretty cool all
right no he is he's a cool guy
um
this was his response ready so the
original article
tweet was
uh dan crenshaw on staff physically
assaulted by white ring attackers
shouting eyepatch mccain now he was
never physically assaulted we just saw
the video right okay
dan crenshaw retweets it
this is what happens when angry little
boys like alex stein don't grow up and
can't get girlfriends
so
doesn't play sports uh-huh doesn't crush
puss that is correct is that what we're
20
brendan shove
you just so dan crenshaw just brian
cowland us yes he's not playing sports
and crushing puss
alex stein's reply he just retweeted him
dan i'm two feet taller than your buddy
and
again
that is something
by the way that that just hurts anytime
somebody can say that to you yeah that
really really hurts so
without understanding
irony or anything do you want to see
what dan crenshaw's
subsequent tweet was that day
okay you just saw what he said there
right
okay do you want to read this one
uh yeah first john 4 20. oh [ __ ]
whoever claims to love god yet hates a
brother or sister is a liar for whoever
does not love their brother and sister
whom they have seen cannot love god whom
they have not seen hashtag sunday
thoughts
hey dan
i'm pretty sure that alex stein and
people like myself and royce and uh you
know a bunch of other people i'm not
going to speak for them but i think
one of the biggest
sort of disagreements we have with you
fundamentally is that
we don't want to send a bunch of kids
from this country over to get their
eyeballs blown out and their legs blown
off and get murdered and also to go over
there and bomb civilians and kill
children
see i think that that's
that's just it buddy
um it's we don't hate you i don't really
hate any we hate the fact that you
as somebody who lost your eye in a war
we hate what you represent yeah you
you're using your war injury to hide
behind while at the same time sending a
bunch of people off to be injured and
killed in war
without any it's like it's like somebody
who got molested as a kid grows up and
starts molesting kids it's like anybody
that you know somebody who grew up in a
house full of [ __ ] you know out of
control drug addicts grows up and
becomes a drug addict you are you are
basically kicking the can down the road
and you're paying the abuse forward and
that's
how dare you how dare you talk about
loving your fellow man when you're like
with the stroke of a pen
you can kill thousands of people
but that but that's again
and keep in mind ten thousand ten
thousand noodles says congress just
ain't for him dan needs to adopt a
parrot and reinvent himself on the high
seas okay come on that means you're
implying is a pirate